[Music]
on this sunday night
the allegations against admiral art
mcdonald
global news uncovers the details
surrounding accusations of sexual
misconduct
any allegations or any information that
were brought forward
was always quickly and then taken to the
appropriate authorities for the
appropriate action
what did the defense minister know
vaccination
prioritization should essential workers
move up
to get the shot plus the officer accused
of killing george floyd
about to stand trial and the royal
squabble the firm is playing
in perpetuating falsehoods about us the
queen
and the sussexes remain firm on their
break
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we have new and troubling revelations
about the investigation
into allegations of inappropriate
behavior at the military's highest level
global news has learned how the canadian
forces found out about the sexual
misconduct allegation
that forced the newly minted chief of
the defense staff
admiral art mcdonald to step aside while
an investigation is ongoing
in our top story tonight a whistleblower
comes forward with claims about
what the defense minister's office knew
our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stevenson has the exclusive details
mercedes allegations against admiral art
mcdonald surfaced in victoria bc
on february third one day after global
news revealed sexual misconduct
accusations
against general jonathan vance a
confidential source
with direct knowledge of the matter
tells global news lieutenant commander
raymond trotter a 21-year veteran of the
royal canadian navy
was approached by a female subordinate
the source says the woman described an
incident
from roughly a decade ago when admiral
mcdonald was a multinational task force
commander
in canada's north trotter was obligated
to report
what he heard but finding the right
authority to flag the allegations to
revealed the challenges faced by victims
and whistleblowers
when trying to come forward the source
says trotter was bounced between
offices starting with the military's
sexual misconduct response center
which told him it could not receive
reports of sexual misconduct
the source says that trotter contacted
the office for the minister of national
defense
saying he had allegations against the
chief of the defense staff
according to the source the office
passed him to a civil servant
who promised to brief the minister a
spokesperson for minister sajin says
at no point did the source speak with
political staff and would not comment on
whether or not they were aware of the
call
or brief the minister ultimately the
source says trotter reported the
allegation to military police
roughly three weeks after trotter
notified those authorities
defense minister harjit sajin announced
mcdonald was stepping aside
citing a police investigation in a
statement to global news macdonald said
as there is an ongoing investigation and
on the advice of legal counsel
i am not making any statements at this
time
after trotter came forward two sources
say he received two calls from men using
blocked numbers he did not recognize
their voices
but they identified themselves as senior
members of the military and government
both warned him against testifying with
the information he had
and said doing so would jeopardize his
military career
global news has learned that opposition
members of the commons defense committee
plan to subpoena trotter when the
committee meets monday part of a push to
expand its study into sexual misconduct
in the military
defense minister harjit sajin has
insisted that any complaints brought to
his office
have always been handled properly any
allegations
or any information that were brought
forward was always quickly
and then taken to the appropriate
authorities for the appropriate action
two sources say trotter also reported a
second allegation
unrelated to the incident of alleged
sexual misconduct
concerning mcdonald that incident
allegedly involved comments made by
senior naval officers
about sexual bondage referencing fifty
shades of gray
according to sources the comments were
made during a zoom call
attended by more than a hundred naval
officers one source says trotter quickly
received blow back
including from his chain of command
robin
mercedes stevenson with this exclusive
story
to canada's vaccination campaign now
provinces will be receiving more doses
of the four approved coven 19
shots in the coming weeks while there is
a priority for the country's most
vulnerable
there is a growing debate over who else
should be included
heather yorks west explains high school
teacher thomas
shea is one of many canadians unable to
work at home
he's an essential worker but he's not
able to get immunized right now
it makes me a little bit anxious i feel
devalued as a worker
the national advisory committee on
immunization has recommended essential
workers be immunized during the second
phase of the vaccine rollout but so far
many provinces are focusing instead on a
person's
age or medical condition ontario says
essential workers like teachers and farm
workers
will be immunized in the latter part of
phase two
focusing on hard-hit neighborhoods until
then we need to be aware of that a lot
of the essential workers
who cannot work from home and have a
high rate of
contact with other people are actually
in these highest risk neighborhoods
essential workers not only face an
increased risk of contracting covid19
they're also more likely to pass the
virus on according to modeling out of bc
prioritizing them for vaccine could save
lives if we prioritize high contact high
risk people earlier
we could save between 100 000 or up to
200 000
infections and up to 600 deaths by
vaccinating people who are at risk of
exposure and transmission and that's
because we prevent cases from happening
in the first place
we're seeing especially in the
households of essential workers
if you have say you know six or seven
people in the household they can all get
infected and of course this could then
spill over into
the community at large it's something
alberta has seen happen
several times after large outbreaks in
meat processing plants
but instead of prioritizing meat
processing employees next for vaccine
alberta is instead focusing on age
allowing
anyone 50 or older to be immunized next
if we just use an age-based approach
with an online booking system in english
it is very clear i think that we will
not
reach the populations
that are most disproportionately
impacted in some parts of the country
covet 19 numbers are once again
on the rise and with vaccine supply
limited
there is significant need to get the
next phase of canada's vaccine rollout
right heather urex west global news
calgary
ontario recorded nearly 1300 new cases
of kova 19 today
just as restrictions are set to ease in
more regions
as of midnight the stay-at-home order
expires for toronto and peel
both regions will move into the gray
lockdown zone
that allows non-essential retailers to
reopen at limited capacity
but gyms and personal care services will
remain closed
restaurants will be restricted to take
out service only
quebec will move more regions into the
lower orange alert level at midnight
but montreal will remain in red the
highest level
because of rising cases involving a
highly contagious variant
residents across the rest of the
province will now be permitted to eat
inside restaurants and go to the gym
the nighttime curfew will be pushed back
to 9 30 p.m
the u.s senate has narrowly approved a
sweeping pandemic relief package
the 1.9 trillion dollar bill will
provide direct payments of up to
fourteen hundred dollars
for most americans it also extends
emergency unemployment benefits
and provides aid to cash strap state and
local governments
the bill passed without one republican
vote in a 25-hour senate marathon
it now heads to the house for final
passage
president joe biden has signed an
executive order aimed at ensuring
voting rights as he marked the
anniversary of bloody sunday
and the civil rights march in selma
alabama
elected officials in 43 states
have already introduced over 250
bills to make it harder for americans to
vote
we can not let them succeed
i'm signing an executive order to make
it easier for eligible voters to
register to vote
and improve access to voting
on this day in 1965 hundreds of civil
rights activists began marching from
selma
to alabama's state capitol montgomery to
protest the struggles black people had
voting
despite a constitutional right state
troopers attacked the demonstrators as
they crossed the edmund pettus bridge
the shock of the assault on non-violent
protesters
sparked a nationwide uproar it led to
the passage of the voting rights act
later that year the city of minneapolis
is bracing for the start of derek
shovin's trial
chauvin is the former police officer
accused of murdering
george floyd the disturbing and
heartbreaking video of floyd dying
with a knee on his throat set off
protests around the world
and the calls for justice haven't ended
especially from his family
jennifer johnson reports fencing and
barriers have been erected around the
hennepin county government center
with the trial of former minneapolis
police officer derek shovin begins
monday
assaultive or riotous behavior towards
anyone
will not be tolerated setting fires to
structures of any kind will not be
tolerated
ahead of the trial protests have been
held in minneapolis and outside the
governor's home in saint paul
demanding justice not only for floyd but
other victims of police brutality
we want a fair shot without having our
hands tied behind our backs a boot on
our neck or a gun to our children's head
or our own head
the former officer faces charges of
murder and manslaughter
after being videotaped kneeling on
floyd's neck for almost nine minutes
my brother said i can't breathe multiple
times but the officer sat on his neck
with a smirk on his face
[Music]
my brother screamed tell my kids
i loved him as his soul left his body
some fear the trial could be delayed
after the minnesota court of appeals
ordered a judge to reconsider adding
third degree murder to chauvin's charges
much easier for prosecutors to prove
third degree is basically extreme
indifference to someone else's life it's
if you're doing something so
reckless and dangerous that you don't
care about if someone dies
many protesters say an acquittal of
chauvin should not happen
the eyes of the world are going to be on
minnesota with this upcoming trap
activists say they plan to protest
outside the courthouse every day of the
trial
you have to have compassion you have to
feel
what these people are feeling and if you
can't don't call yourself a good person
the trial comes after the house last
week passed the most ambitious plan in
decades
to overhaul policing nationwide the
george floyd justice policing act
that act which aims to combat police
misconduct and the use of excessive
force
faces a tougher fight in the senate but
has the support
of president joe biden jennifer johnson
global news
washington still ahead more troubles for
new york's governor
could the allegations against andrew
cuomo force him to step down
plus the pope's historic visit to iraq
in the u.s one of that country's most
famous faces in the pandemic is under
fire in two separate scandals
four different women have now accused
new york governor andrew cuomo
of inappropriate conduct that's on top
of allegations his administration
covered up deaths from kova 19 in the
state's nursing homes
as jackson prescott reports the once
rising star in america's coveted crisis
now faces calls to leave office i'm not
going to resign
i work for the people of the state of
new york they elected me
defiant new york governor andrew cuomo
is clinging to power
but for how much longer without
explicitly saying it
he he implied
to me that i was old enough for him and
he was lonely
this week cuomo's former aide charlotte
bennett came forward with her story of
alleged sexual harassment
i thought he's trying to sleep with me
the governor is trying to sleep with me
cuomo has apologized
without admitting wrongdoing i now
understand
that i acted in a way that
made people feel uncomfortable
but his problems don't stop there he and
his administration are under fire
and under investigation for allegedly
hiding the number of covid deaths in the
state's nursing homes
the new york times reports some of those
efforts were underway
just as cuomo started writing a book
about his pandemic achievements
in a state where more than 47 thousand
people perished
we need a full investigation into the
allegations of sexual harassment we need
a full investigation into the nursing
home scandal
new york city is currently it's a
stunning fall for a governor who won an
emmy for his popular pandemic briefings
this was the trajectory of covet
in our state there was once talk of a
future presidential run
now there are calls for cuomo to resign
or be impeached
one of the reasons why he's facing the
difficulties he's facing
and he doesn't have the friends around
him who might stand up for him the cuomo
name is legendary in new york
his father was once governor his brother
is cnn anchor chris cuomo
is it true that this was the swab
that the nurse was actually using on you
who helped promote the elder cuomo
during the pandemic
and is now ducking one of the biggest
stories in the country and obviously
i cannot cover it because he is my
brother
now left with few friends and even fewer
defenders
a political dynasty has come crashing
down as the embattled governor tries to
hang on
jackson prosco global news
pope francis has wrapped up an historic
visit to iraq with an open-air sunday
mass for
thousands of people and visiting
war-ravaged regions of the country
with a message consistently focused on
peace the pontiff is aiming at building
a better rapport between christians and
muslims in the country
he toured an area where people faced
religious persecution under the control
of the so-called islamic state
francis also spent time with abdullah
kurdi the syrian father
whose two-year-old son alan drowned in
the mediterranean
along with his mother and older brother
the heartbreaking image of the toddler
washed up on a beach in turkey in 2015
turned the world's attention to the
plight of refugees
still ahead the racist abuse endured by
britain's soccer players
grows beyond the stadium
you're watching global national
for years major league sports stayed
away from the black lives matter
movement
nfl players wanting to protest racial
injustices
were banned from kneeling during the
american anthem then this past summer
when anti-racism activism surged
the sports world picked up the ball but
in the uk the rise of virtual racism
has left some pro soccer players feeling
defenseless
redmond shannon explains when english
soccer leagues resumed in empty stadiums
after
the first lockdown it was just a few
days after the killing of
george floyd players united to take a
knee
but at one game they looked up to see
this
white lives matter a banner paid for by
a
fan and with the stands still empty it
appears
more people are going online to send
racist messages
to players you know i've received
messages i've received multiple messages
in
dms um you know saying you know
horrible things race issues are now
coming to the to the front of agendas i
think it's more in people's minds
and i think there is a bit of a
reluctance sometimes for people to
accept that that's the way that things
are going barely a week goes by without
another player highlighting the vile
racist abuse they get online football
association president
prince william tweeted that the
responsibility extends to the social
media platforms
instagram which is owned by facebook
says it's making changes
to ban repeat offenders and to better
filter
direct messages the players union and
retired stars
say it's not enough how easy it is for
people simply to
make a a fake profile and engage in this
kind of racist abuse
it's shocking in its scope shaka hislop
played in the premier league
and world cup in the 90s he set up a
racism
education charity they also have to do
more about
people just making these fake online
profiles
the problem is verifying user identities
goes against
the anonymous free speech ethos of many
online platforms
activists say racism's root causes need
to be addressed
too it's very much society's problem
races are not footballs but then it's
coming back at the moment in social
media
abuse across social media is nothing new
but it appears as though the voices of
these high-profile sports stars
could be forcing change the british
government is now promising legislation
designed to hold social media giants
more accountable redmond shannon global
news
london up next
royal showdown the queen celebrates the
commonwealth before harry and megan
tell all
tonight a real-life royal rift is making
for must-see tv
the duke and duchess of sussex prince
harry and megan
are breaking their silence on why they
left the royal family
as michael couture explains the
exclusive interview with oprah winfrey
may come at a cost for the couple if
that comes with
risk of losing things i mean i've
there's a lot that's
been lost already the build up has been
like nearly nothing
viewers have seen before and inside an
unvarnished look at the british royals
from prince harry and megan
set the broadcast nearly a year to the
day
the couple attended their last official
family function
as royals i don't know how they could
expect
that after all of this time we would
still just be silent
if there is an active role that the firm
is playing
in perpetuating falsehoods about us
the firm is the not so friendly term to
describe the often reserved and
sometimes restrictive royal family
some see similarities between this
interview and the one given by princess
diana
decades ago in which she broke her
silence
alone i can't begin to imagine what it
must have been like for her
going through this process by herself
all those years ago
diana's interview shattered the public
image of the royal family and observers
believe
it could happen again after megan and
harry's candid conversation
they spent years trying to repair their
image in the public eye
it's going to be exactly the same with
this one no matter what harry and megan
say
people are going to be very quick to
form opinions perhaps in an effort to
counter any negative narrative the queen
released this message ahead of
commonwealth day
trying to paint the royals as relatable
in our everyday lives we have had to
become
more accustomed to connecting and
communicating
via innovative technology which has been
new to some of us
notably absent from the video were megan
and harry who relinquished royal duties
a year ago in part because of the
intense media glare
we all know what the british press could
be like and it was destroying my mental
health i was like this is
toxic moving to california helped the
couple escape that life
but granting these types of interviews
will thrust them right back
into the spotlight mike lacouter global
news
and the prime time special airs tonight
you can watch it right here on global
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm robin gill
we leave you tonight with a fight on the
ice in two different provinces
wearing bright yellow hoodies montreal
brothers mark and scott brodie skated
for nearly 10 hours
to raise funds for the alzheimer's
society they were inspired by toronto's
stephen mcneil who also skated for 10
hours
it's his ninth year skating in honor of
his mother who suffered from this
disease
thank you for watching good night
[Music]
you